[Music]
let's go to emma in
welcome to miami what's up emma
hi dr darwin how are we doing
um i'm doing okay oh so not good at all
not good at all
a little bad okay so fill me in i'm
sorry what's going on
well
i overheard my husband's friends
and him
making fun of me
oh man what about
uh well first of all we're newlyweds
after our honeymoon my husband and his
friends were having a group video call
i chatted with them for a bit and then i
excused myself to go for a walk then i
made the biggest mistake of my life
i forgot something
and turned back to get it
but everyone had thought that i'd left
his friends had started to ask him
about our honeymoon
and started poking fun at him
eventually one of his friends
asked him if
if
if my looks
were still a problem
for him
he told her he loved me and that we had
a great honeymoon
and
yeah
it was a group of them
so so he told her that you know i'm
beautiful on the inside
despite you know him liking
lighter-skinned slimmer girls
he told them that
we can't have it all you know
she insisted on asking him if
he felt like he had downgraded from his
ex oh jeez yeah who who was yeah
light-skinned and slim
and he said
maybe oh but he said that
he said that but i make him happy
and another one of his friends i'm not
sure if she was trying to help
said that maybe
it would help a lot if i had lost some
weight i'm i'm not morbidly obese or
maybe a little chubby
but right now um nothing feels the same
anymore
and
i've been ruminating wishing that i
didn't turn back
hold on hold on hey emma
you did not make the biggest mistake of
your life
okay
you didn't
and i'm heartbroken that this is how you
ended up with this info
um but you didn't make a mistake you
didn't screw up anything here okay
you
my friends are not at fault here okay
now i'm not saying you're perfect and
i'm not saying you're not doing right
you know what i'm saying but you didn't
screw this up okay
you're allowed to walk into your own
home that you share with your husband
and
yeah
i'm just like my stomach's dropped i
could just i can't imagine the hurt
you're feeling right now
um
so how long ago was this
five weeks ago
and so my
here's a couple of
well
so he's not here okay
and i've got all kinds of thoughts and
all kinds of things running through my
head but he's not here
um
so the only person i can talk to right
now is you is that cool
so
it would be easy for me to join you and
piling up on him
but this call is about you and your
wellness okay
and so
um
my first question to you is have you
told him
i i haven't i
i feel embarrassed for turning back
and
listening
as well and
he would feel bad about it i guess he
should he should you don't need to
protect him he's a grown man he's going
to be telling his friends and a bunch of
women
that um
yeah yeah i had to go with jv here when
it comes to the looks department
um
then
he can be a grown man and look you in
the eye
see what i'm saying you didn't screw up
you don't need to defend him
he's clearly okay with having
conversations about you and your body
out to the public
um
the only person he's not having them
with is you right
yeah but but how
it wouldn't change
anything because that's how he truly
feels
right and so the next the next question
change
certain
of my characteristics or
or what society
calls physical attractiveness i can lose
weight
but
there are other things that i just
cannot change about myself
emma
yeah man
i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry
here's here's the challenge you find
yourself in okay
he's not telling you the truth about how
he feels about you
and you're not telling him the truth
about what you know
and what's going to happen in short
order if it hasn't happened already
is that within your home
you live with a threat now
and you're gonna create a special safe
cocoon that only you live in
and he's not gonna know what it is he's
just gonna know that his wife is distant
from him
and
then he's going to be about solving that
distance with any number of ways if he's
a person of character he will
continually try to reach out to appeal
to your heart and say why is there
distance between us
and if you don't tell him you're
choosing to respond to his lack of
character with dishonesty
or he might choose to
be a scumbag and approach that
or
try to solve that distance between the
two of you by going back to these other
women that he has on his video chats and
tell them whatever and try to create
connections with them
okay
but the reality is there's a huge gap in
your marriage and no having the
conversation isn't going to solve how he
feels
who cares this isn't about society
and this quite honestly isn't about the
people on the chat
this is about your husband
and this is about you
this is about your marriage and right
now you don't feel safe in your own home
you don't feel safe in your own skin
right
you can't live
moving forward with this ambiguity
but can he really love me if
i'm not attractive
so when when
here's the challenge
you heard part of a conversation that
sounds awful and i would love to talk to
him on the phone one day man i'd love to
have this dude on the show
i'd like to talk to this dude in private
quite honestly not in a macho kind of
way but i'd like to have a conversation
with this dude
bonehead
um but here's a reality here's reality
is is since as mad as i am
and as sensitive as a topic as this
you heard a part of a conversation
and you have created an entire narrative
around the part of the conversation you
have without going to him and saying hey
this is what i heard
is that fair
yeah
so
my wife did not marry brad pitt
close close yes she didn't
right
and
i imagine
i know there are because has told me
that i look feral sometimes well that is
true i don't when i get in hunting
season i don't always bathe and shave
and shower anyway
so there are seasons when
right and then there's times that she
says man when you're dressed up and she
said the worst part about my new job is
that when i was working at universities
i wore a suit and tie every day and
she's like dude you look good like you
look real good and now you just wear
t-shirts and you kind of look like a
slob
right so here's what i'm telling you i'm
trying to make i'm trying to to lighten
this the our conversation a little bit
but
yes
she might have a perfect picture in her
head of a professional basketball player
who's six six and has great calves and
super great muscle i'm not that guy
but she'll also tell you that she thinks
i'm handsome and she thinks i'm really
good-looking
right
that's less of the issue to me the
bigger issue to me is a deep violation
of trust
that your
husband
did not talk to you
and has not been honest with you
and
either that or
when he's trying to be the cool guy with
his friends
who are bagging on you and he doesn't
come to your defense
or maybe he felt like he was coming to
your defense by saying yeah you know
what she doesn't look perfect but i love
her and he doesn't understand how much
that hurts you
see what i'm saying
and he doesn't understand the
existential tale spin that you are in
because you married a man that does not
believe you are beautiful
and nobody i don't care who you are
nobody wants to be married to someone
who doesn't believe they're beautiful
inside now right
yeah
so i think
here's what i don't want you to do
i don't want you to avoid this
conversation and wake up in five years
and still believe that you're married to
a guy that doesn't find you beautiful
and it's less about him
it's more about you don't feel beautiful
in his presence you see what i'm saying
that's different
what does he think or is yeah exactly
how embarrassing is that
and
i just yeah oh god what
i don't talk bad about your husband but
what an idiot good grief man
um and here's the other side
i also think it's important for men to
have
guy friends
that they can
sit down and have hard truth
conversations with
right
because i don't want a generation of men
who grow up living in silence and then
just end up sitting in a recliner
cracking a beer every night just to get
through the day they got to have people
that they talk about hard things with
but those things that they talk about
their friends have got to especially
when it talks about their wife and their
wife's body or their girlfriends and
their sexuality man there's got to be
some consensus about what's cool to talk
about what's not
and where i am and where i'm not
unfortunately you've probably heard me
say this if you listen to this show not
by your hand but in your lap
you didn't ask for this
and you walked in your home which you do
not have to apologize for and you heard
your talk your husband talking in a
public space in your home that you do
not have to apologize for and you
re-entered a conversation you were just
in before you went out for your walk you
just talked to these two-faced people
who were like oh hi great to see you oh
my gosh how are you
right
you had
no fault in this zero
and i'll say fault but i don't really
mean it the only fault you've had now
i don't want to say fault because i
think you're processing traumas what's
happening you're processing
really heaviness
i
the only fault here is that you haven't
sitting down and said i heard this and
this hurt me in this way
and so what i would tell you is don't
let your husband's
failures here
rob you of your character and of your
beauty and of your strength
okay
you're worth being loved and you're
worth being believed you are beautiful i
don't care what society's that stuff's
nonsense man
it's nonsense
and it man it may be that your husband
is just a sweet loving guy who's an
absolute boneheaded [ __ ] and there's a
lot of men who are like young men who
like that need to be taught
he may be an absolute character-free
idiot
and your life would be better if you
made some hard decisions you see what
i'm saying
yeah
um
okay i just do a lot at you tell me
where you are
if we were dating i know
i would have left him
okay
what's the best move what's the best
move for emma to make emma feel safe
make emma feel loved
to let emma know that she is beautiful
what's the next step
i guess to accept this and and move on
emma have you listened to anything
no
we're not accepting this no listen we're
not accepting this and moving on
okay
are you in an abusive relationship are
you safe no
yeah i am okay
if you hadn't have heard this
conversation would you think he loves
you deeply
i would okay
i i really would
is he worth a conversation
i would want to think so are you worth
that conversation
yes
okay
do you promise me
you will confront this head-on directly
i will
here's what i want you to do before you
have that that meeting
i want you to write down what you heard
i want you to write down how you feel
because what he's going to say is this
no you are not a supermodel but i
married you i gave you my everything i
love you
our sex life is good our honeymoon was
great i love you everything about what
i'm demonstrating here says i love you
and that's when you're going to start
feeling crazy and so i want you to have
already written down so you can read
yeah but you told a group of people that
i wasn't beautiful
and now i will for the rest of my life
wonder does my husband wish he was
somebody else
you told a group of women
before because they were checking back
in right
right it would seem as if they they've
had this conversation before yes
you regularly had conversations with
other men and women
about not being attracted to me or about
my body not being enough
i need you to understand what that did
to my insides
to who i look in the mirror and see now
because now you became just another
faceless person in society who judges me
because my skin is too dark who judges
me because i don't fit in a size fill in
the blank who judges me because
and you were supposed to be my safe
place
that's why we got married
you were my safe place and i was yours
and you're not safe anymore you're just
like one of them
okay
i want him to hear that
and in every marriage there has to be
space there's been times when my wife
sat down and said
hey
physical fitness john is a big deal to
you and your mental health and if you
don't exercise you don't think clearly
and if you're not exercising and eating
right you're not okay and i've noticed
like
you're having to wear xl shirts now like
you've gotten you've put on a lot of
weight
um i'm worried about you
big picture
right
my we've had that conversation and i
gave her permission to get to have that
conversation with me
but that's different than i ain't
attracted to you because you're too bi
you see what i'm saying there's a very
big difference and so i don't want
people to listen to this and say oh so
you're not ever no you're allowed to
have hard conversations
you have to have hard conversations
right or i'm struggling with attraction
right now and here's why but that
conversation goes directly to you in a
spirit of love and connection not a
spirit of blame and judgment and
especially doesn't go to all my buddies
first and by the way guys listen to this
nobody needs to know what happened on
your freaking honeymoon shut up that's
yours good grief
keep something sacred for crying out
loud idiots
jesus
i got the greatest guy friends on planet
earth the greatest guys on planet they
know everything about me you know what
they don't know what happened on my
honeymoon because that's mine that's me
and my wife right good grief this is
ridiculous all i have to say
i'm starting to get mad again
i want you to write that stuff out and i
want you to let him know hey we need to
have a hard conversation
okay
and here's the thing
emma if you don't want to be married to
him anymore
or you need some space from him
you need to be honest with him about
that conversation
okay okay
if you want to stay married to him but
you don't know how just yet
i want you to be honest about that
conversation like you told me if you
were dating this is over i'd be out of
here
but i said for better or worse and we're
going to figure this out
unless this is past or worse you see
what i'm saying
yeah you may need a girlfriend to sit
with you and walk you through this all
right and well i may not walk you
through it but sit there with you while
you do this okay but
this conversation is really important
and then what happens next is really
important
okay
okay okay
i'll ask you one more time do you
believe you're worth this conversation
i am do you believe him
um that you deserve a safe place
i do okay
i'm so so sorry this happened to you do
you believe you have zero no none no
fault in walking into your own home
99
zero
got it
got it
yeah zero okay
i will tell you this
the spirit of the person i'm talking to
is stunning
okay
thank you
stunning
and
nobody gets another judgment on you got
it
you're on my you're on my team now
cool
thank you all right um do me this huge
favor
let me know when you've had this
conversation write us back
let us know how it goes
and if he wants to be on the show if you
want both wanna be on the show about
what next i'd love to have you back
and if he doesn't
cool
before i let you go i have to be honest
about this you may have this
conversation he may be sick he may say
you're right i made a mistake we
shouldn't have gotten married
that could happen
it'll be devastating and hard
and if that happens
know that's walking into that room
and hearing that conversation
was the greatest thing that ever
happened to you
because you shed yourself of this idiot
and you will find someone who believes
in you and it believes that you're
beautiful and is thinks
god every day that they found you
that person exists
those people exist not just one person
like a needle in haystack there's
bajillions of people
and if you have this hard conversation
and he gets down on both knees and says
i screwed up bad
here's what i meant i didn't defend you
well i screwed it up because i was a
coward and i'm gonna do better
and let me tell you i've been there
i wish i could say things differently
and i've had to say i screwed this up
and i was a coward and i was a wimp and
i fill in the blank here i want to be
better
i've done that in my marriage several
times
and
this may be a moment of clarification
for your marriage moving forward
he will never ever
talk to those knuckleheads on zoom
caller in person again those
relationships are over because you're
not gonna be a part of those people's
lives and since y'all are one now he's
not either
and on and on and on
but this conversation comes with a risk
either way
you are better on the other end of it
i'm heartbroken for you
and
we'll be walking alongside you on this
one thank you so much for being brave
and thank you for the call emma